right and thanks to all the organizers
for giving me the chance to speak today
so my talk is about optimization of the
hypercube buyer sums of non-negative
circle polynomials and this is joint
work with an M core pitch and t-mobile
and since the audience was really
diverse I thought I also spent the first
couple of slides by just setting some
really really basic background and
context and then I will introduce sums
of non-negative circle polynomials and I
will give you an overview of constraint
polynomial optimization with these
polynomials and after that we will
tackle optimization over the hypercube
okay so the underlying problem of my
talk is a constrained polynomial
optimization problem that is we have
real multivariate polynomials F and a
bunch of G one two Gs and we minimize
the polynomial F subject to the set K in
which every polynomial GI is
non-negative so K is the basic closed
semi algebraic set defined by the
polynomials GI and optimal value of this
problem will be denoted with FK star and
clearly this optimization problem is
equivalent to finding the largest
Raeleen number lambda such that f minus
lambda is non-negative for all X in K so
the non convex optimization problem can
be reduced to the question of deciding
non negativity of a polynomial over a
certain set and this is a key challenge
in real outright geometry with a write
wide range of applications like in
robotics control theory economics
theoretical computer science and so on
and although this problem is decidable
it is well known that it is in general
np-hard and therefore one is interested
in finding sufficient conditions to
certify non negativity which are easier
to check so-called certificates of non
negativity and you all know the standard
example for such certificate namely sums
of squares because obviously if you can
write the polynomial as a sum of squared
polynomials then this polynomial is
nothing but it is even better than that
because I can also test if a polynomial
is a sums of squares and even find
decomposition as Westie compositions by
a semi definite programming and semi
definite programming is a convex
optimization problem which we just saw
that can be seen as a generalization of
linear programming and how an SOS can be
cast as in semi definite optimization
problem we also already saw yesterday I
think James talked so let's get back to
constraint polynomial optimization
problems how do we solve these problems
and the good news here are that there
exist various positive standards and
relaxations to tackle these kind of
problems in many cases and these methods
were studied intensively by means of
aspects like exactness and quality of
the relaxations the speed of the
computations and general geometric
aspects of the underlying structures and
a very famous approach for solving
sea-pups is assess relaxation so what is
that I will give you the dual
formulation with polynomials so we relax
the non negativity condition to an SOS
condition and this as well as
formulation is given by poutine us+
stands out
so we have here that the polynomial can
be written as a sum of product of SOS
polynomials and the constraints GI and
bounding the degree of the involved
polynomials give us the parameter F SOS
D which converged
when we let go D to infinity to the
optimal value FK star and finding a
dreary D as well as certificate can be
done by n by solving an SDP of size and
to the OD and for solving STPs
there exist various software so olicity
refused they do me all map st.pete III
masak and many more but from the
practical point of view it is also known
that solving some indefinite programs is
where our worry is very time consuming
so the corresponding semi-definite
programs quickly get very large in size
which often is an issue for problems
with high degree or many variables and
also it is known problems
still if SDP of size and to the ot
really can be solved in time and to the
OD and to tackle these issues current
research focuses mainly on creating
better solvers and exploiting additional
structures like symmetry and sparsity
and in contrast our idea is to use other
non negativity certificates independent
from these classical SOS certificates
and before I get more into depth let me
fix some rotations so we are working
here over our X sub n to D this is the
vector space of real polynomials and
variables of degree at most two D in
this space we have the cone of non
negative polynomials denoted by P and 2d
and in this cone they live the cone of
some of the squares Sigma into D okay
now let's talk about some polynomials
the main actor for these polynomials is
a circle polynomial a circuit polynomial
is supported on a finite set a and has
this specific form and meets some
special conditions on the support which
I want to explain by means of this
picture where you can see the support
plotted as these red dots and the blue
square
so first the Newton polytope of this
polynomial is a simplex with even
vertices of J so these red dots here
belonging to these J and these are even
vertices means that all alpha J are even
and as you can see this Newton polytope
of this polynomial coincides with this
convex hull of the support of this
polynomial and we have one additional
interior point this beta lying strictly
in the interior of this simplex that
means we can write beta uniquely as a
convex combination of the vertices and
this lambda J which are the barycentric
coordinates relative to the vertices and
the third condition is a necessary
condition for F to be non-negative
namely that the coefficients here
corresponding to the vertices of the
simplex have to be strictly positive
so in short a circuit polynomial is a
polynomial who support forms and even
simplex with one additional interior
point and the term circuit is chosen
since the support that forms a circuit
which is minimally affine dependent set
and an example of such a polynomial is
the famous Max Motzkin polynomial which
is the first polynomial found to be
non-negative but not SOS so let's take a
look at the support here and in fact
this little picture shows the support of
the Motzkin polynomial so we see yeah it
meets all these three conditions so it
is indeed a circuit polynomial and for
every such circuit polynomial we can
define the so-called circuit number as
this product where in the numerator are
the coefficients corresponding to the
vertices of the simplex and in the
denominator and the exponents there are
the relative very centric coordinates so
this number can be derived by the
initial circuit polynomial immediately
if you give me a circuit polynomial you
can easily compute this number and the
key fact now is that testing non
negativity of circuit polynomials can be
done easily via this number namely with
this condition here and by easily I mean
we only have to solve a system of linear
equations
[Music]
okay then riding a polynomial as a sum
of non negative circuit polynomials
abbreviated s-song gives us a
certificate of non negativity and let's
define the set of some polynomials more
formally so we will denote it with CM to
D and it consists really of all
polynomials and n variables of degree at
most two D which can be written as a sum
of non negative
and we can say it more namely this set
is indeed a convex cone clearly living
inside the non-negativity cone and if we
compare the SOS cone with this new song
cone we see that these two cones
intersect but not contain each other and
in more detail the song cone only lies
in the SOS cone in these cases so in the
univariate case in the quadratic case
and for binary cortex which are exactly
the Hilbert cases where the SOS cone
coincides with the non-negativity cone
and on the other hand the song comb
doesn't contain the SOS cone in these
cases so for all grades larger or equal
than four and four variables with it
more than two terms
and an important result about song
polynomials and the song cone is that it
is fallen dimensional in the
non-negativity cone because this is a
necessary condition to establish some
polynomials as a certificate which is
really useful in practice and now I want
to mention two properties which are in
strong contrast to SOS to their score
namely on the one hand the song cone is
not closed under multiplication and also
not closed undertaking affine
transformation of variables and from an
optimization perspective the second
condition says that a problem
formulation obtained by fine
transformation of variables may lead to
a problem of different tractability with
the sound methods which means on the one
hand that a representation
representation of the problem has to
mate very carefully so this makes the
process of algorithm give design more
demanding but on the other hand even a
small change in representation can lead
to a song certificate or simplify an
existing one yeah so note maybe in this
context that every affine transformation
of variables applied to for example the
Motzkin polynomial never leads to an SOS
certificate
close under affine transformation of
variables okay so and some we have here
really as well as independent Newcomb
which lives inside the cone of non
negative polynomials and now the
question is how can one check
efficiently whether a polynomial has
such a sum decomposition and this brings
us back to constraint polynomial
optimization so we already saw that this
was STP approach for this problem and
now we would like to have an
approximation for F K star with song
polynomials so we would like to relax
this non negativity conditions somehow
to a song condition and the I would say
the key strengths of Blasius relaxation
is that it gives a converging hierarchy
hierarchy converging to our optimal
value and to guarantee such an SOS
certificate it uses putting us positive
tenders so one could hope to translate
maybe the proof of poutine as positive
standards into the song world but
unfortunately this is not possible since
the song cone is not closed under
multiplication so we cannot form
something like a quadratic module for
some polynomials for proving such a
positive standard by pooty nom but there
also are good news namely we can use
abstract positive stands that's from
real algebraic geometry in emilich
ravines positive standards to obtain I
would say Schmidt can like positive
standards for some polynomials and
what is that this gives us a
representation of our polynomial as the
sum so if we have a product of some
polynomials and products of the
constraints so Putin R would be
Linnea would be linearly in the
constraints but here we have to use
really products of the constraints and
for those who are a little bit more
familiar with this topic and analog
positive stands that's what's given by
genres like Allen and Shaw for signals
by on the so called sums of arithmetic
geometric Exponential's ok so now we can
also define a parameter F functi as the
largest number gamma such that F minus
gamma has this representation is given
by the positive standards in addition we
bound the degree and obviously this
parameter gives us a lower bound for FK
star based on the maximum allowed degree
in the representing polynomials and it
grows monotonically indeed so it really
yields converging hierarchy which is
degree dependent to the optimal value of
our problem FK star so the provided
hierarchy is really complete
okay and now last step we want to
compute this parameter was a suitable
optimization program and there are more
good news because we can do this by a
relative entropy program remember as
well as can be done while some
indefinite programming and here we have
a relative entropy program and what is
that so we have three variables two of
them are non-negative and we minimize
linear functional subject to linear
constraints and such a conic constraint
and this conic constraint defines the
relative entropy cop and what is good
about that is a relative entropy program
it's a convex optimization program due
to the joint convexity of this function
defining the relative entropy comb and
Moreau Bobby can solve them efficiently
with interior point methods due to the
existence of a computational tractable
barrier function for the function
defining the relative entropy code so
computing a degree D song certificate
can be done by an explicit relative
entropy program and note this relative
entropy comb program is of size and to
the
and now with this in mind we want to
tackle optimization over the hypercube
so we want to prove some complexity
balance some complexity bounds over the
hypercube
so
let's consider a constrained hypercube
optimization problem which is a special
case of a constrained polynomial
optimization where the feasible set is
restricted to some of the vertices of
the boolean hypercube and again we are
minimizing an N variate polynomial F
regarding to some equality constraints
which are given by these quadratic
polynomials with two distinct real roots
AJ and BJ
so these equality constraints give us
the really general hypercube AJ BJ to
the N and why do we check here this
really general hypercube remember the
song Kohn is not closed under affine
transformations of variables so we
really have to prove things here in a
very very general setting ok so we have
these equality constraints and then
we're additionally constrained the
hypercube with some inequalities p.i
feasible set will be denoted with Coley
H P so the n-dimensional hypercube age
constrained by a bunch of polynomial
inequalities given by curly P which is
the set of these P I and this class of
optimization problems really lies at the
core of theoretical computer science
because we can't for example cast max
cut or Sparsit cut problem or the
maximum constraint satisfaction problem
as this kind of constraint have a cube
optimization problems and the main idea
here in this word is to find
certificates with good complexity in the
number of variables and and the maximal
totally greedy
and what is known about SS complexity
for the boolean hypercube so here we
know that every feasible and very odd
constraint hypercube optimization
problem with constraints of degree at
most P there exists a degree 2 n plus 2
D as well certificate and we already saw
or I think I already mentioned that
finding a degree D as well as
certificate for non negativity of a
polynomial F 1 the constraint hypercube
can be performed by solving an SDP of
size and to the OD and this is why the
corresponding ramyon matrix is of this
size and since every real symmetric
matrix which admits or which is positive
semi-definite admits a cholesky
decomposition this yields also an
explicit SOS decomposition with at most
n to the OD squared polynomials these
are results Noom result about in as well
as certificates and now we prove that
analogous results also hold for song
certificates namely for every polynomial
non-negative over the constraint
hypercube with inequalities of degree at
most D there exists degree of n plus T
songs certificate and for an N very odd
polynomial which is non-negative over
the constraint hypercube we have the
result that if there exists a dong the
degree D song certificate then there
also exists a short degree D song
certificate involving at most n to be OD
many non-negative circuit polynomials so
we can reduce ourselves in such a degree
D song certificate really to enter
od many non- circles and we show these
results under the assumption that the
constraints P I so the cardinality of
the set P is polynomial in N which is
usual the case because otherwise the
polynomial of the problem gets less
tractable from the optimization point of
view and the proof earlier for the
second statement is to really analyze
such a song certificate for polynomial
and then to note that one can bound the
number of involving some polynomials and
these product of the constraints in a
certain way so which yields that we also
have a bound for the whole number of
terms namely n to the OD and I actually
want to outline the proof of the first
statement inner so we have that
assumption that we have a polynomial F
and bear yet and this is non-negative
over the constraint hyper cube of degree
at most D and then let's take a look at
the proof so first that we develop a
conic a data function for songs on the
hypercube so that is we define a
function for every vertex of the
hypercube as this product so this is a
function of degree n and then we have to
note two things namely the term chronic
a delta function is really justified
because this function takes zero for
every vertex except V and for B it takes
the value 1
and as the function is a product or it's
a product of the constraints it is also
very obvious that we can write this
Kanaka Delta function in this Schmidt
can type namely as a sum of product of
non-negative reals and products of the
constraints GRI then second step we show
that polynomial and variate of degree 2
d plus 2 which vanishes on our hyper
cube can be represented in this way so
as sum of some polynomials times the
constraints and sum of some polynomials
and the negative constraints and why is
that so first it is known that
polynomial which vanishes over the
hypercube
admits such such a representation namely
as a sum of products of some polynomials
and the polynomials representing the
hypercube and then we really show that
these PJ JJ are of this form here and
how do we do that we look at these
polynomials P and decompose them as a
sum of monomials and then we tackle
really each in
individually and here we can see that if
this monomial is a monomial X square
means that if a is positive and M has a
exponent an even exponent then we're
fine because then this monomial is
actually already a non-negative circuit
polynomial so it is song so we're done
and otherwise we can add a non-negative
circuit polynomial having this non
monomial square as an interior point and
then we can subtract the redundant
monomial squares so the edges so I add a
circuit polynomial which has the right
interior term but then I have to get rid
of the vertices of the simplex coming
from the circuit polynomial and the
little trick is here that I can then
push this minus sign from subtracting
into the GJ's because I can take this
representation and then I only have to
make sure that the involve degrees don't
exceed but that's also fine by
constructions so we know that polynomial
which vanishes over the hypercube can be
written like this
then third step when restricted to the
hypercube I can write my polynomial in
terms of the conic identity function
like this so here I separate the
vertices by if they lie in the
constraint hypercube and the remaining
one which only comes from the hypercube
and remember we assume that our
polynomial is non-negative over the
constraint hypercube which means that
this polynomial F evaluated at a point
of the constraint hypercube is
non-negative because we assume this but
there might exist at vertex here in the
remaining vertices such that F takes a
negative value at this vertex and if
that happens then we let PV be a
polynomial under the constraints such
that also evaluated at this verdicts
this polynomial Texan negative term and
otherwise one so we can prove that this
point on we can be really represented as
this some where here really every term
is non-negative
okay and then you have to note that the
right hand side is a polynomial of
degree at most n plus D so this might
happen here because of the Kronecker
Delta function is of degree N and we
assume that our constraints are of
degree at most T so the right hand side
will be a polynomial of degree at most
and plus D and this is a representation
over the hypercube so f minus the
right-hand side vanishes over the
hypercube and then I can use the result
from step two to represent my polynomial
in this way so really some here which is
a degree at most n plus the polynomial
and this finishes
okay and now I want to mention some
findings about the about positive
strands at Sur namely after we presented
our positive standards which is more
like Schmitt can type we asked if there
also exists representation which is
linear in the constraints so putting our
like positive standards and we can
answer this now in a negative way
because when working on this hypercube
we found a function and with this
function here parameters eyes by a
natural number a this function admits
this function is first positive strictly
positive over the hyper cube plus -1
but unfortunately admits no poutine I
like some representation if the
parameter exceeds this term here
and this function can be seen a little
bit like a generalized kronecker delta
function because at the or once vector
it takes the value 1 a and at all other
vertices 0 so kind of geometrically
obvious that if a then exceeds a certain
number that this the products okay so
and because this there are the
polynomials which don't have such a
poutine are like some representation
over the hypercube we can also say that
in general there exists no equivalent of
poutine as positive Jen that's for some
polynomials which does not say that may
be for special cases they might exist
such a representation but so general not
I think
so long polynomials provide the belet's
certificate for optimization over the N
barrier to hypercube HP name will be
showed here that for a polynomial F
which is non-negative on the constraint
hypercube with degree at most D there
exists a degree n plus T song
certificate and if admits degree D song
certificate over this constraint
hypercube then there is also a short D
some certificate for this polynomial
involving at most n to the OD many
negative sir and let me conclude with
some open problems so we saw that
solving or finding a degree D song
certificate can be done by solving a
relative entropy program of size and to
do D and now the question is if we also
can do this in time and to the OD only
if small or a short small degree
certificate exists is not necessarily
given that the polynomials in this
representation also have small
coefficients and the difficulty is here
that one really has to restrict the
search space of n various degree D song
certificates to a subset of n to the OD
to really be able to formulate a
relative entropy program in time and to
the OD and proof of this statement of
the short song certificate only
guarantees us such that is such a short
certificate
exists but this means or a priori I'd
say now not clear how to find such as
some certificate and then coming from
the fact that the song cone is not
closed under affine transformation it
would be very interesting to study it's
a fine closure because I mean the affine
closure
strictly contains the song cone and
still yields non negativity certificate
so it would be interesting to study this
object and also then to ask how can we
compute such extended songs certificates
efficiently so how to test membership
then in this okay
thank you those are fine closure
contains SOS polynomials oh that's a
good question um I don't think so
but
I'll have to look into it I think
if your epicurean is a replaced by
general finite in the world you have
seen a conclusion so so if I have a clue
either replaced by a finite Fred Meyer
yeah we're working here on the finite so
I don't take the cube
I only take the Bernice's ah sorry yeah
that would be also an open problem so I
think we have such things but how
exactly they look like in terms of the
variable and the greedy
I guess we have a long break down sink
[Applause]